This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. New Year's Eve is just around the corner, and whether you love it or hate it, you are probably putting more thought into what you'll be doing that night than any other night of the year. I'm not much of a New Year's Eve person myself. Best reporter Katie Thornton. Listen, I like parties. I like dancing. But there's just too much pressure on New Year's Eve. You want me to set the tone for my whole year in one night of obligatory fun? And yet, despite my crankiness, I do have one New Year's guilty pleasure. Something about it that I do love.
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马尔斯。新年夜就在眼前，无论你爱它还是恨它，你可能都在花心思琢磨那天晚上该怎么过，这甚至超过了一年中的任何其他夜晚。我自己其实不是那种热衷于过新年夜的人。最佳记者凯蒂·桑顿。听着，我喜欢派对。我喜欢跳舞。但新年夜的压力实在是太大了。你想让我在一个强行狂欢的夜晚，为我整整一年定下基调吗？然而，尽管我脾气暴躁，我确实有一个新年夜的秘密癖好。那就是我确实很喜欢它的某些方面。
And it is the most New Year's's Eve of all New Year's rituals. The massive, confetti-filled extravaganza that is New Year's Eve in Times Square. Every year I see footage of the celebration and almost despite myself I end up tearing up. There's all these people piled together, smiling, waving, full of hope for the future, and inexplicably stoked about a glorified disco ball getting slowly impaled on the spit of One Times Square, and inexplicably stoked about a glorified disco ball getting slowly impaled on the spit of one Times Square, and then everybody makes out and Ryan Seacrest is there? Bonus.
而且这是所有新年仪式中最具新年夜特色的一场。那就是时代广场新年夜那场盛大的、洒满彩纸的狂欢。每年我看到庆祝活动的画面，几乎不由自主地都会流泪。所有这些人挤在一起，微笑着，挥着手，对未来充满希望，而且莫名其妙地为一个迪斯科球缓缓插在一号时代广场的尖顶上而感到狂热，莫名其妙地为一个迪斯科球缓缓插在一号时代广场的尖顶上而感到狂热，接着所有人开始热吻，而瑞安·西克雷斯特也在现场？额外惊喜。
But one of the most iconic parts of the whole celebration happens after the clock strikes midnight and the fireworks go off. When the massive crowd bursts into New York, New York. I think this is the big reason it hits me so hard, despite not being a New Year's Eve fan. It's that Times Square, especially on New Year's, is almost mythologically New York. Times Square is the neighborhood of brilliant signs, skyscrapers, and hot dog carts. It's got cavalier office workers breezing past ambling tourists without breaking their important sounding phone conversations. Basically, it's a caricature, the movie version of New York.
但整个庆祝活动中最标志性的部分之一，发生在钟声敲响午夜、烟花绽放之后。当巨大人群突然齐声合唱起《纽约，纽约》时。我认为这是让我感触如此之深的重大原因，尽管我并不是新年夜的粉丝。那就是时代广场，特别是在新年期间，几乎具有纽约的神话色彩。时代广场是一个充满巨幅广告牌、摩天大楼和热狗摊的街区。这里有漫不经心的上班族，从闲逛的游客身旁轻快地走过，却不中断他们听起来很重要的电话交谈。基本上，这就是一个漫画版、电影版的纽约。
Over 100 million people come to Times Square every year to take a bite out of the Big Apple. And the neighborhood is consistently one of the top tourist destinations in the world. But the Times Square we know today didn't just happen. In the late 80s and early 90s, much of the neighborhood was seized by the government and reshaped by a powerful group of business owners. It's a transformation that saw a neighborhood emptied out, and it raises questions about how private money should shape public space. The land we now call Times Square was, for about 3,000 years, home to the indigenous Lenape people. But since Manhattan was colonized by Europeans,
每年有超过一亿人来到时代广场，想要咬一口“大苹果”。这个街区一直是全球顶级旅游目的地之一。但我们今天所知的时代广场并非自然形成的。在80年代末和90年代初，该街区的大部分土地被政府征用，并被一群强大的企业主重塑。这是一场让街区被清空的转型，它引发了关于私人资金应当如何塑造公共空间的质疑。我们现在称之为时代广场的土地，大约3000年来一直是原住民莱纳佩人的家园。但自从曼哈顿被欧洲人殖民以来，
the neighborhood has lived many lives. Before it was Times Square, it was a place called Longacre Square, which was a place for the carriage trade, all kinds of livery, stables and the like. This is Lynn Segalen, a professor emerita at Columbia Business School, who has written books on the many faces of Times Square.
这个街区经历过许多次更迭。在它成为时代广场之前，这里曾是一个叫做朗格克尔广场的地方，是马车贸易、各种马车租赁、马厩及类似场所的聚集地。这是琳恩·塞加伦，哥伦比亚商学院的名誉教授，她曾撰写过关于时代广场多面风貌的书籍。
She says that in the late 19th century, Longacre Square was the part of town with more horses than people, situated just north of the more bustling parts of Manhattan. It was in no man's land, okay? There barely had streetlights on Broadway at that point. But what happened next is exactly what you'd expect. New York kept growing and growing. And speculators, as they do, pulled some of the city's money and energy north onto the cheap land of Longacre Square.
她说，在19世纪后期，朗格克尔广场是城里马匹多过人的地方，位于曼哈顿繁华地带的正北方。这里当时是不毛之地，好吧？当时百老汇甚至几乎没有路灯。但接下来发生的事正是你所预料的。纽约不断地扩张。投机者们也照例将这座城市的一些资金和精力吸引向北方，来到朗格克尔广场这片廉价土地上。
By the early 1900s, a handful of theaters were doing decent business in the neighborhood. Not long after that, a subway stop opened at Longacre, connecting the fledgling area to the rest of the city. But what really brought the neighborhood into its own was the arrival of its most famous resident. In 1903, the New York Times broke ground in Longacre Square, and a year later, they petitioned the city for a name change.
到20世纪初，少数几家剧院在这个街区做着还算不错的生意。没过多久，一个地铁站在朗格克尔开通了，将这个刚刚萌芽的地区与城市的其他部分连接起来。但真正让这个街区大放异彩的，是它最著名的居民的到来。1903年，《纽约时报》在朗格克尔广场破土动工，一年后，他们向市政府申请更改地名。
The neighborhood has been called Times Square ever since. This was the beginning of a new era for Times Square. Thanks to the theaters and the subway and the vote of confidence from the paper of record, the neighborhood was happening. In just a few years, it went from a tentatively hip part of town to a thunderous triumphant hotspot for celebrations, for work, and for nightlife. More and more theaters cropped up, turning New York into the country's leading theater city. thunderous triumphant hotspot for celebrations, for work, and for nightlife.
从此这个街区就被称为时代广场。这是时代广场新时代的开始。多亏了剧院、地铁以及这家权威大报的信任投票，这个街区开始火热起来。短短几年内，它就从一个试探性时髦的城区，变成了一个用于庆祝、工作和夜生活的轰轰烈烈、凯旋般的热门聚集地。越来越多的剧院如雨后春笋般涌现，使纽约成为全国领先的戏剧之城。用于庆祝、工作和夜生活的轰轰烈烈、凯旋般的热门聚集地。
More and more theaters cropped up, turning New York into the country's leading theater city. So it became the most famous theater street in the world. It was a lot of nighttime gaiety and restaurants were on rooftops because this was an era before you had air conditioning. And in the summer it was quite hot. And so you had a lot of really elegant rooftop palaces where people would go for dinner and drinks. It was during this period of rapid growth
越来越多的剧院如雨后春笋般涌现，使纽约成为全国领先的戏剧之城。于是这里成了世界上最著名的戏剧街。这里有着许多夜间欢娱，餐厅设在屋顶上，因为这是一个还没有空调的时代。夏天相当炎热。因此你有许多非常优雅的屋顶宫殿，人们会去那里吃晚餐和喝饮品。正是在这段快速发展的时期，
that Times Square also got a new tradition. On New Year's Eve in 1907, the Times sponsored the first ball drop to welcome in 1908. The falling ball was paid for by Adolf Ochs, sponsored the first ball drop to welcome in 1908. The falling ball was paid for by Adolf Ochs, then publisher and owner of the New York Times. Ochs borrowed the idea from an old Navy ritual that started in England in the 19th century. Every day at 1300 hours, Greenwich Mean Time,
时代广场也迎来了一项新传统。在1907年的新年夜，《时报》赞助了第一次降球仪式来迎接1908年。这个下落的球由当时的《纽约时报》出版商兼所有者阿道夫·奥克斯出资赞助。奥克斯从19世纪起源于英国的一个旧海军仪式中借用了这个想法。每天格林威治时间13点整，
a ball would drop on the top of England's royal observatory so that sailors could set their clocks and navigation equipment. Times Square was the perfect location for a big display like a ball drop. That's because the square lies at a diagonal intersection, unlike most of Manhattan, which is built on a grid. Big, wide streets come together at Times Square, creating these long urban vistas, meaning from almost anywhere in the neighborhood, you could see the ball. So in 1907, Ox rigged a ball to the top of One Times Square, where the Times was headquartered.
一个球会从英国皇家天文台的顶端落下，以便水手们校准他们的时钟和导航设备。时代广场是举办像降球这样的大型展示活动的完美地点。那是因为这个广场位于一个斜向交汇的路口，这与曼哈顿绝大多数建立在网格系统上的街道不同。巨大而宽阔的街道在时代广场交汇，形成了这些长长的城市景观走廊，这意味着从街区的几乎任何地方，你都能看到那个球。所以在1907年，奥克斯在《时报》总部所在地——一号时代广场的顶端装置了一个球。
And that was the start of an annual tradition that became the biggest celebration in a neighborhood built for celebrating. Over the following years, Times Square just kept getting bigger and more glamorous. But the neighborhood only had a few glorious decades as New York's hottest club because in 1929, everything changed when the stock market crashed. Then you have the crash, and then people don't have as much money to go out, and if they do, they're going to movie theaters, going to see motion pictures less expensive than live theater. Playhouses shuttered.
而这开启了一项年度传统，并成为了一个为庆祝而建的街区中最盛大的庆祝活动。在随后的几年里，时代广场不断变得更大、更迷人。但这个街区作为纽约最热门俱乐部的辉煌时期只持续了几十年，因为在1929年，随着股市崩盘，一切都变了。接着迎来了崩盘，人们没有那么多钱出去玩了，如果他们真的出门，他们会去电影院，去看比现场戏剧花费更少的电影。剧场纷纷关门。
Restaurants closed too. And then you had the war. Times Square never really had a chance to recover. With World War II came blackouts and electricity rations that shut off its neon lights. Then after the war, people fled to the suburbs. A lot of industry left the area. And by the late 1940s, the neighborhood's businesses were mainly scraping by on cheap movies and carnival games.
餐厅也关门了。然后战争爆发了。时代广场再也没有机会恢复元气。随着二战的到来，灯火管制和电力配给切断了这里的霓虹灯。战后，人们逃往郊区。大量工业撤离该地区。到了20世纪40年代末，该街区的企业主要靠廉价电影和嘉年华游戏勉强度日。
You have all sorts of rides and games and shooting galleries to win prizes. All sorts of circus-like entertainment. You had a kind of Coney Island Times Square. At this point, Times Square was busy, but kind of broke. Property owners needed a way to bring in real money, and carnival games just weren't cutting it. The problem was that Times Square was built largely as a theater district, and it was hard to turn a theater into a shoe store, for instance, or a tailor. There was, however, one type of show that could consistently pull in a crowd. I can't tell you the exact date that the sex shows started, but they were there before
你拥有各种各样的游乐设施、游戏和射击游戏来赢得奖品。各种马戏团式的娱乐活动。你拥有了一种科尼岛式的时代广场。此时的时代广场虽然热闹，但有点破产。业主们需要一种能带来真金白银的方法，而嘉年华游戏根本不管用。问题在于，时代广场在很大程度上是作为戏剧区建造的，要把一个剧院变成鞋店或裁缝铺是很困难的。然而，确实有一种演出能够持续不断地吸引人群。我无法告诉你色情秀开始的确切日期，但它们在
the 60s. There had always been raunchier shows in Times Square, with opera and vaudeville operating side by side. But in the mid-20th century, sexy shows like Burlesque weren't the exception. They were the norm. Smaller shops got in on the action too, complimenting the big theaters. So in the back of bookstores, you had the adult books, okay?
60年代之前就已经存在了。时代广场一直都有比较低俗的表演，歌剧和杂耍并存。但在20世纪中叶，像滑稽歌舞杂耍这样性感的表演不再是例外。它们成了常态。小商店也加入进来，与大剧院相辅相成。所以在书店的后面，你会看到成人书籍，好吧？
And in 1966, you had the first Peeps, 25 cent Peep shows introduced. And as they would say, 25 cents for a peep machine in a private booth was a rare bargain in an expensive city. White-collar workers, mostly male, would trickle in from their offices, disparaging the neighborhood by day while quietly patronizing it at night. It was common knowledge what was for sale in Times Square, but these transactions were largely taking place out of sight in back rooms.
而在1966年，推出了第一家“偷窥秀”（Peeps），也就是25美分的成人看片箱。正如他们所说，在一个物价昂贵的城市里，花25美分在一个私密隔间里看一台偷窥机是一笔难得的便宜交易。白领工人，大多是男性，会从办公室陆陆续续赶来，白天贬低这个街区，晚上却悄悄光顾。时代广场兜售什么东西是人尽皆知的，但这些交易大多是在后房里不为人知地进行着。
That is until the early 70s, when a Supreme Court case called Miller v. California really opened up possibilities for smuts in Times Square. The interpretation of obscenity changes, and then it all breaks open. In Miller v. California, the court basically said that what was obscene depended on local norms. So in a big coastal city like New York, all bets were off. Suddenly, showing pornography, explicit books, movies, or live shows, was completely legal.
直到70年代初，最高法院审理了一起名为“米勒诉加利福尼亚州案”（Miller v. California）的诉讼，才真正为时代广场的淫秽内容打开了可能性。对淫秽内容的定义发生了变化，然后这一切彻底爆发了。在“米勒诉加利福尼亚州案”中，法院基本上裁定，什么是淫秽取决于当地的标准。因此，在纽约这样的大型沿海城市，一切限制都不复存在了。突然之间，播放色情内容、露骨的书籍、电影或现场表演，完全合法了。
And Times Square stepped onto the scene as the definitive porn capital of New York City. So sex became an industry. I mean, you had massage parlors, you had live nude shows, you had peeps, you had topless bars, you had hardcore sex films, you had porn emporiums, you had adult bookstores, you had, I mean, it was a cornucopia of commercial sex. You had everything you could possibly imagine. The result of all this—the big, struggling theaters, the pornography, the sex trade—all of it contributed to a version of Times Square that was a far cry from the glamorous theater
而时代广场作为纽约市无可争议的色情之都登上了历史舞台。于是性变成了一个产业。我的意思是，这里有按摩院，有现场裸体秀，有偷窥箱，有上空酒吧，有硬核色情电影，有色情大卖场，有成人书店，我的意思是，这是一个商业色情的聚宝盆。你能想象到的应有尽有。所有这一切的结果——苦苦挣扎的大剧院、色情制品、性交易——这一切共同塑造了一个与昔日迷人戏剧区相去甚远的时代广场。
district it had once been. By the 70s, Times Square was a gritty, tough place. I was a teenager, and for a woman, it was just not a place you wanted to be. It was dicey. Add to this the fact that New York City nearly went bankrupt in the 1970s and cut back on vital services like sanitation. So it wasn't just dicey, it was divey and a bit dirty. Rolling Stone would come to crown a stretch of Times Square, the sleaziest block in America.
到了70年代，时代广场成了一个粗粝、艰难的地方。我当时是个青少年，对一个女人来说，这里根本不是你想呆的地方。这里很危险。再加上20世纪70年代纽约市几乎破产，削减了环卫等基本服务。所以这里不仅危险，而且破旧还有点肮脏。《滚石》杂志甚至给时代广场的一段路冠以“美国最藏污纳垢的街区”的称号。
You had assault, you had battery, you had fights, you know. You basically had a range of activity from minor crime to serious crime, meaning murder and rape, that was part of the territory in those decades. This was pretty much rock bottom for Times Square, at least according to the government. By this point, city and state officials saw Times Square as a sort of emblem of the city's decline. The city also saw that it was losing out on tourism dollars. Times Square was no longer a top destination for visitors. One indicator, by the late 70s, attendance at the neighborhood's annual New Year's Eve fanfare had dropped by 95% from mid-century. This at a time when
这里有袭击，有殴打，有斗殴，你知道的。你基本上能看到从轻罪到重罪的一系列活动，这意味着谋杀和强奸，在那些年代里都是司空见惯的一部分。对于时代广场来说，这几乎是谷底，至少在政府看来是这样。到了这个时候，市和州的官员将时代广场视为这座城市衰落的一种象征。市政府也意识到它正在失去旅游收入。时代广场不再是游客的首选目的地。一个指标是，到70年代末，该街区年度新年夜狂欢活动的参与人数比世纪中期下降了95%。而在当时，
tourism to the rest of the city was booming. The city was desperate to clean up the neighborhood and convinced residents and tourists alike that Times Square was a place worth visiting. And it's this desperation that set off a pair of events that would push Times Square out of its seedy past and into its bright, family-friendly future. That's after the break. We're back with reporter Katie Thornton. By the start of the 80s, New York officials were sick of their once premier destination
该市其他地区的旅游业却在蓬勃发展。市政府迫切希望清理这个街区，并让居民和游客相信时代广场是一个值得一游的地方。正是这种绝望情绪引发了一系列事件，将时代广场从其藏污纳垢的过去推向明亮、适合家庭的未来。广告之后继续。我们欢迎记者凯蒂·桑顿回归。到80年代初，纽约官员对他们曾经首屈一指的迷人目的地沦为笑柄、藏污纳垢和充满危险的窝点感到厌烦。
for all things glamorous being a laughing stock, a den of vice and danger. So in 1981, they announced a plan to clean up the neighborhood. New York would use eminent domain to condemn much of Times Square. Eminent domain allows the government to seize private land for public use. It has a long history of being used to dispossess black and brown communities. Owners are compensated for their property, but they don't have any choice but to sell.
因此，在1981年，他们宣布了一项清理该街区的计划。纽约将使用征收权（eminent domain）来征收大部分时代广场。征收权允许政府为了公共利益征用私有土地。它有着长期被用来剥夺黑人和棕色人种社区财产的历史。业主会因其财产获得补偿，但他们别无选择，只能出售。
In New York, Eminent Domain had been used before to build Central Park, expand New York's drinking water reservoir, build Lincoln Center. And now, the city and state were partnering with private developers to empty out Times Square so it could be filled back up with more desirable businesses. There's a big significant, complicated, complex plan to change all the uses, to wipe out the bad uses and put in place good uses. Bad was all the commercial sex and porn, and good uses were office, return of live theater, and other forms of entertainment.
在纽约，征收权以前曾被用来建造中央公园、扩大纽约的饮用水水库、建造林肯中心。现在，市政府和州政府正与私人开发商合作，清空时代广场，以便重新填入更理想的商业设施。这是一个庞大、重要、复杂的计划，旨在改变所有的土地用途，消灭不良用途，并建立好的用途。不好的用途是所有商业色情和黄色内容，而好的用途是办公场所、现场戏剧的回归以及其他形式的娱乐。
Cleaning up the city was a euphemism for a lot of things you probably already know about New York in the 80s and 90s. Urban renewal, Mayor Giuliani, broken windows, policing, and we'll get into that. But in Times Square specifically, the cleanup was also motivated by homophobia. Remember, this was in the middle of the AIDS crisis.
清理这座城市是许多你可能已经知道的关于80年代和90年代纽约的事物的委婉说法。城市复兴、朱利安尼市长、破窗效应、警务执法，我们等会细聊。但在时代广场，清理行动的背后也有恐同情绪的推动。记住，这正处于艾滋病危机的中期。
And Times Square wasn't just home to the sex industry. It was also one of the few places in the city with a thriving gay scene. People, straight and queer, made their living in Times Square. They made their life there. They went out, screwed around, fell in love. For a lot of people, it was home. But these were not the people that the city and state wanted representing New York.
而且时代广场不仅是性产业的发源地。它也是这座城市中为数不多的拥有繁荣同性恋文化的场所之一。直人和酷儿都在时代广场谋生。他们在那里生活。他们外出、胡闹、坠入爱河。对很多人来说，这里就是家。但这些人并不是市政府和州政府希望用来代表纽约的人。
So in 1990, New York condemned multiple blocks of Times Square, kicking out hundreds of businesses, as well as poor and elderly residents. At the time, it was the largest redevelopment project in the country. But around the same time the plan went into effect, the real estate market tanked. Some tenants who had promised to move in pulled out,
所以在1990年，纽约征收了时代广场的多个街区，驱逐了数百家企业，以及贫困和老年居民。在当时，这是全国最大的重建项目。但就在该计划生效的同时，房地产市场崩溃了。一些承诺搬入的租户退出了，
and other prospective buyers weren't biting. Much of Times Square was emptied out, but there were very few businesses willing to fill it back up. This became a problem for all the businesses that stuck it out, a handful of hotels and theaters who made it through the bad times, and of course, the New York Times.
其他潜在买家也不买账。时代广场的大部分地区都被清空了，但几乎没有企业愿意重新填满它。这成了所有坚持下来的企业的问题，包括那些挺过艰难时期的少数酒店和剧院，当然还有《纽约时报》。
And that brings us to the second ingredient in Times Square's transformation, from den of vice to big, bright tourist hub. Arthur O. Solzberger Jr., son of the paper's publisher and heir to the title, had a vested interest in making the neighborhood shine again. Some people were turning down jobs at the paper because they didn't wanna work in the neighborhood. And so Sulzberger led the charge for some of the area's property owners to take matters into their own hands.
这就把我们带到了时代广场转型的第二个要素，即从藏污纳垢的窝点转变为明亮的大型旅游枢纽。小阿瑟·奥茨伯格，该报出版商的儿子兼头衔继承人，有着让这个街区重新焕发光彩的切身利益。有些人因为不想在这个街区工作而拒绝了该报的工作。因此，苏尔茨贝格带头让该地区的一些业主采取自主行动。
He set his sights on an urban planning tool that had been gaining popularity among the country's business leaders. It was a tool that could let a group of unelected property owners generate enough money to transform their neighborhood, all while skirting some of democracy's red tape. The tool was called a business improvement district, or a BID. These are kind of like private organizations that are managing urban space. This is Daniel Kudla, a sociologist who has written a lot about BIDs.
他将目光投向了一种在全国商界领导人中越来越受欢迎的城市规划工具。这是一种可以让一群未经选举的业主产生足够资金来改变他们街区面貌的工具，同时还能绕过一些民主制度的繁文缛节。这个工具被称为商业改进区（BID）。这些有点像管理城市空间的私人组织。这是丹尼尔·库德拉，一位撰写了大量关于商业改进区文章的社会学家。
Essentially they're a group of business and or property owners within a designated geographical area who end up paying an annual tax to supplement local services to their commercial district. The concept of a bid first popped up in Toronto in 1970, when a group of downtown merchants had lost a lot of customers to nearby malls. To remedy this classic suburban era story, they asked the council to make it mandatory for all downtown shops to pay into some local beautification projects in an attempt to bring people back. They put up some extra streetlights, some nice signs and banners, and they saw a bump in
本质上，它们是指定地理区域内的一群企业主和/或业主，他们最终通过缴纳年度税款来补充其商业区的当地服务。商业改进区的概念最早于1970年出现在多伦多，当时一群市中心商户由于附近的购物中心而失去了大量客户。为了解决这个经典的郊区时代的故事，他们要求市议会强制所有市中心商店为一些本地美化项目付费，试图把人们吸引回来。他们安装了一些额外的路灯、漂亮的标语和横幅，并看到了顾客数量的回升。
customers. From there, bids spread across North America. The rules around them varied from city to city and state to state. But in New York, for example, all you needed was a simple majority of property owners to vote to approve a bid. And then every property owner in the area had to pay in. The owners could then pass the cost on to renters. It was like a tax. There was no opting out. The bid would then pool all that money and spend it on what they or their chosen staff thought would help the neighborhood. So this can be anything from hiring private security, doing beautification upgrades, to street furniture, lighting, or even just marketing, promoting, branding the neighborhood.
从那时起，商业改进区在北美各地传播开来。围绕它们的规则因城市和州而异。但在纽约，例如，你只需要获得业主中的绝对多数投票批准即可建立商业改进区。然后该地区的所有业主都必须出资。业主随后可以把成本转嫁给租户。这就好象税收一样。没有退出的选择。商业改进区随后将所有这些资金汇集起来，并将其花在他们或他们挑选的工作人员认为有助于街区的事情上。因此这可以是任何事情，从聘请私人保安、进行美化升级、到城市家具、照明，或者仅仅是营销、推广、塑造街区品牌。
The city technically had to approve bids formation and budgets, but after that, the bid would be in charge. Solzberger saw what bids had done for other cities and neighborhoods, and he figured that a bid might just finally be the solution to the city's drawn out cleanup efforts. So he rallied the property owners. Certainly going to be the New York Times. It's certainly going to be the theater owners. It's certainly going to be the New York Times. It's certainly going to be the theater owners. It's certainly going to be the retailers.
市政府在技术上必须批准商业改进区的成立和预算，但在此之后，商业改进区就全权负责了。苏尔茨贝格看到了商业改进区为其他城市和街区所做的一切，他认为商业改进区可能最终会成为解决该市旷日持久的清理工作的方案。于是他召集了业主们。这肯定会包括《纽约时报》。这肯定会包括剧院业主。这肯定会包括《纽约时报》。这肯定会包括剧院业主。这肯定会包括零售商。
They want to have an impact and help shape the new Times Square. In 1992, the majority voted to create a bid. They got their approval from the city and it was official. The brand new Times Square bids started collecting their fees and began the work of making something from nothing. Remember, at this point, Times Square was pretty empty. So, the BID's first mission was to make sure their neighborhood was appealing enough to bring people back in for a wholesome brand of fun.
他们想要产生影响并帮助塑造新的时代广场。1992年，多数人投票决定创建一个商业改进区。他们得到了市政府的批准，这正式成立了。全新的时代广场商业改进区开始收取费用，并开始了无中生有的工作。记住，此时的时代广场相当空旷。因此，商业改进区的首要任务是确保他们的街区足够吸引人，以把人们带回来享受一种健康的娱乐。
And it was really important to start sending the message of change, that Times Square was going to be a new place. It was cleared of porn. It was cleared of porn. It was cleared of the commercial sex. And so they needed to promote Times Square as a healthy place for people to come back to. Over the next year, the Business Improvement District got to work. They employed a brigade of unarmed security officers.
传递变革的信息非常重要，即时代广场将是一个全新的地方。这里清除了色情内容。这里清除了色情内容。这里清除了商业色情。因此他们需要将时代广场推广为一个人们可以放心回归的健康场所。在接下来的一年里，商业改进区投入了工作。他们雇佣了一支由非武装保安人员组成的队伍。
They hired street sweepers to pick up trash, stashing all their brooms in an empty theater. And they put on big public events, highlighting things Times Square was known for in its golden years. So from the bids formation, we tried to celebrate each one of those in a unique way. This is Tom Harris, the current president of Times Square's Business Improvement District, which is now called the Times Square Alliance. He wasn't part of the group at that time, but he knows a lot about its history. We started with a taste of Times Square,
他们雇佣了清扫街头垃圾的清洁工，把所有的扫帚藏在一个空剧院里。他们举办大型公共活动，突出时代广场在其黄金时代闻名的特色。因此，从商业改进区的成立开始，我们试图以独特的方式庆祝其中的每一项。这是时代广场商业改进区（现已更名为时代广场联盟）现任总裁汤姆·哈里斯。他当时并不是该组织的一员，但他对它的历史了如指掌。我们从“时代广场品味日”开始，
inviting people into Times Square for a taste of some of these famous restaurants. The Times Square bid also put on an event called Broadway on Broadway, closing down the street and putting on a big show of famous songs from musical theater. And that was the symbol that Times Square is family friendly. But alongside all these efforts to reshape their neighborhood's image, the Times Square
邀请人们来到时代广场品尝其中一些著名餐厅的美食。时代广场商业改进区还举办了一项名为“百老汇在百老汇”的活动，封锁街道并举办了一场大型演出，上演音乐剧中的著名歌曲。这就是时代广场适合家庭的象征。但除了所有这些重塑街区形象的努力之外，时代广场
bid had something even bigger planned. It was an event that was meant to convince the world that Times Square was exactly where they wanted to be. And what better way to do that than by harkening back to another famed local tradition and giving people the whole square. In the porn years, the annual event had been a bit underwhelming. People standing around in the cold, watching more or less the same old ball drop. But all that changed for New Year's 1993, when the Times Square bid overhauled the annual extravaganza. They take new images.
商业改进区还有更大的计划。这是一个旨在让世界相信时代广场正是他们想去的地方的活动。还有什么比回归另一个著名的当地传统并把整个广场呈现给人们更好的方法呢？在色情泛滥的年代，每年的活动有点让人失望。人们站在寒冷中，看着差不多还是那个老掉牙的降球活动。但这一切在1993年新年夜改变了，当时时代广场商业改进区彻底改造了年度狂欢。他们拍摄了新照片。
Times Square looking good. They had the ball redesigned. Listen to that crowd. They're watching the ball move. There's a big 300 watt bulb at the top and another one at the bottom. They made it a performance. They were presenting the essence of entertainment, of joy, of gathering together to celebrate in this iconic place.
时代广场看起来很棒。他们重新设计了球。听听那群人的声音。他们在看着球移动。顶部有一个300瓦的大灯泡，底部还有另一个。他们把它变成了一场表演。他们展现了娱乐的精髓、欢乐的精髓，以及在这个标志性地方聚集庆祝的精髓。
You know, they made it even more than what it was to begin with. Eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two, one, happy new year! Woo! Jack, check it out! In the first moments of 1993, fireworks lit up Times Square, dazzling visitors. And there was confetti, hand-tossed invisibly from the buildings above by volunteers. Colorful paper saturated the sky, making the whole of Times Square this idyllic urban snow globe. Look, it's a confetti. Oh, brother. That's a new addition.
你知道，他们让它超越了最初的意义。八，七，六，五，四，三，二，一，新年快乐！呜！杰克，看这个！在1993年的最初时刻，烟花照亮了时代广场，令游客眼花缭乱。还有彩纸，由志愿者从上方的建筑物隐蔽地用手抛洒。五彩缤纷的纸屑洒满天空，使整个时代广场变成了这个田园诗般的城市水晶球。看，那是彩纸。哦，天哪。这是一个新增加的内容。
It's like we're in the middle of a snowstorm, but it's live in Times Square with a deluge of confetti. It might seem like an age-old tradition, but this was a first. Even Dick Clark gave a shout out to the bid and the scene they created. The business improvement district has dropped 500 balloons here. The bid made it magical, made it a spectacle. They spared no expense in doing that. And that was fine because the point of it wasn't to turn a profit. Here's Tom Harris again. It was important for the Alliance not to make this the most profitable event of the year.
就像我们正处于暴风雪中，但这是在时代广场现场，伴随着倾盆而下的彩纸。这看起来可能是一个古老的传统，但这绝对是第一次。甚至迪克·克拉克也向商业改进区以及他们创造的场景大声致意。商业改进区在这里投放了500个气球。商业改进区创造了魔法，创造了一场视觉盛宴。他们在这样做的过程中不惜成本。这很好，因为这样做的目的不是为了获利。这是汤姆·哈里斯再次发言。对联盟来说，重要的是不要把这变成一年中最盈利的活动。
It was to make this a civic event that we produce and deliver free to the entire world. After all the work they'd done all year, the street sweeping, the patrolling, the events, the Times Square bid wanted all eyes on the neighborhood. And they got what they wanted. On New Year's Eve, when we welcomed the world there, the world sees a cleaner, safer, family-friendly Times Square. This image of a more approachable Times Square stuck with the public. More people started coming into the neighborhood. Add to that some hefty tax breaks, and new restaurants, shops, offices, and theaters
而是要把它变成一个我们制作并向全世界免费交付的公民活动。在他们一整年所做的工作之后，清扫街道、巡逻、举办活动，时代广场联盟希望所有的目光都聚焦在这个街区。他们如愿以偿了。在新年夜，当我们把世界各地的人们迎到那里时，全世界看到的是一个更干净、更安全、适合家庭的时代广场。这种更平易近人的时代广场的形象深深印在了公众心中。更多的人开始来到这个街区。再加上一些巨额税收减免，新的餐厅、商店、办公室和剧院
moved into spaces that had been sitting empty. Even Disney opened a massive store and theater right in the middle of Times Square. By 1998, the neighborhood had been completely transformed, with the New York Times saying that Times Square was, arguably, the most sought-after 13 acres of commercial property in the world. The transformation of Times Square from its gritty past to its shiny new future was in large part thanks to the savvy and power of the Times Square bid. Within just a few years, the group managed to do what various mayors and politicians had been failing to do for decades.
搬进了长期空置的空间。甚至连迪士尼也在时代广场正中央开设了一家巨大的商店和剧院。到1998年，这个街区已经发生了彻底的转变，《纽约时报》称时代广场可以说是世界上最抢手的13英亩商业地产。时代广场从其粗粝的过去到闪亮的新未来的转变，很大程度上归功于时代广场商业改进区的精明和力量。在短短几年内，该组织设法做到了历任市长和政治家几十年来一直未能做到的事情。
It returned Times Square to something like its former glory. But what happened here wasn't a one-off. In the years since the Times Square bid through their first New Year's Eve party, the bid model has been used again and again to shape cities across the country. Even if you've never heard of a bid, you've almost certainly been inside one. These days, they're part and parcel for how U.S. cities are run. There are about 1000 bids in the U.S. today. New York City has 76. Los Angeles has 40.
它让时代广场恢复了往日的部分辉煌。但这里发生的事情并非孤例。自从时代广场商业改进区举办他们的第一次新年派对以来的几年里，商业改进区模式已被一次又一次地用来塑造全国各地的城市。即使你从未听说过商业改进区，你也几乎肯定置身其中。如今，它们是美国城市运作方式中不可或缺的一部分。美国目前大约有1000个商业改进区。纽约市有76个。洛杉矶有40个。
Milwaukee has 32. Anytime you walk into a commercial district with nicely branded banners, cute flower pots, maybe a neon vested ambassador, you're almost certainly in a business improvement district. In Memphis, bids run historical walking tours. In South Philly, there is a Fall Fest, a Superior Wisconsin Farmers Market. You know, nice little things that, let's be honest, make a city more pleasant and enjoyable. But if bids look too good to be true, it's probably because they are.
密尔沃基有32个。任何时候你走进一个带有漂亮品牌横幅、可爱花盆、也许还有一个穿着霓虹背心的大使的商业区，你几乎肯定身处一个商业改进区。在孟菲斯，商业改进区负责运营历史步行导览。在南费城，有一个秋季庆典，还有一个苏必利尔威斯康星农贸市场。你知道，一些不错的小事情，说实话，让城市变得更舒适、更愉快。但如果商业改进区看起来好得令人难以置信，那很可能是因为它们确实如此。
Or at least, some people think so. Along with many other New Yorkers, I was outraged because not only would you have the clean up, the moral clean up of Times Square businesses, but you would also have a super controlled situation that was going to be operated by and for the private sector. Sharon Zuchin is a professor emerita of sociology at Brooklyn College and at the CUNY Graduate Center who writes about New York and urban sociology. She's lived in New York for most of her life. And while some people saw the transformation of Times Square as nothing short of a miracle,
或者至少，有些人是这么认为的。与其他许多纽约人一样，我感到愤怒，因为不仅你会看到清理，对时代广场企业的道德清理，而且你还会看到一个由私营部门运营并为私营部门服务的超级受控的局面。莎朗·苏钦是布鲁克林学院和纽约城市大学研究生中心社会学的名誉教授，她撰写关于纽约和城市社会学的文章。她一生大部分时间都在纽约度过。虽然有些人认为时代广场的转型简直是个奇迹，
Sharon had a different take. From the time bids first started cropping up in New York City several decades ago, Sharon had major concerns. And not just about Times Square. When the time square bid was formed, there were already about two dozen bids in New York City. I live near the first business improvement district that was created in New York City and noticed security guards. And I started to wonder, what is this organization? Where did it come from? And why are they doing this?
莎朗却有不同的看法。从几十年前商业改进区开始在纽约市出现的那一刻起，莎朗就有着重大的担忧。而且不仅仅是关于时代广场。当时代广场商业改进区成立时，纽约市已经有了大约二十个商业改进区。我住在纽约市创建的第一个商业改进区附近，注意到了保安。我开始想，这个组织是什么？它是从哪里来的？他们为什么在做这件事？
And I started to wonder, what is this organization, where did it come from and why are they taking charge of public space? Sharon says that from the beginning, bids weren't just planting beautiful flowers and sweeping the streets. They played a big role in New York's gentrification. Under Mayor Giuliani, for example, New York City started cracking down on petty crimes, disproportionately arresting New Yorkers of color. You probably know this as broken windows style policing,
我开始想，这个组织是什么，它是从哪里来的，为什么他们要接管公共空间？莎朗说，从一开始，商业改进区就不只是在种植美丽的花朵和清扫街道。它们在纽约的士绅化进程中发挥了重要作用。例如，在朱利安尼市长执政期间，纽约市开始打击轻微犯罪，不成比例地逮捕有色人种纽约人。你可能知道这就是破窗风格的警务，
and bids were a key part of enforcing it. They rousted homeless people from sleeping in various places in their territory, and some of them in midtown Manhattan hired homeless people like to chase other homeless people out of these spaces. And it wasn't a good situation. In the past 30 years, a lot of bids have dialed back some of their sketchiest security practices. But some haven't.
而商业改进区是执行这一政策的关键部分。他们在领地内的各个地方驱赶睡觉的无家可归者，曼哈顿中城的一些商业改进区甚至雇佣无家可归者去把其他无家可归者赶出这些空间。这不是一个好情况。在过去的30年里，许多商业改进区已经缩减了他们的一些最令人反感的安保做法。但有些没有。
Bids operating around the country today have written exclusion orders to keep people out of certain neighborhoods and used high-tech surveillance to monitor public space, all with mixed results as to whether any of this actually yields a meaningful drop in violent crime. The tricky thing about bids is that they aren't forces for good or forces for bad. They are, above all, forces of capital. Most of the choices they make and the things they do come down to one question. How can we make this area nice enough that people want to spend their time and money here?
今天在全国各地运营的商业改进区已经写好了驱逐令，将人们赶出某些街区，并使用高科技监控来监视公共空间，但对于这是否真的能带来暴力犯罪的有意义下降，其效果褒贬不一。商业改进区棘手的地方在于，它们既不是纯粹的正义力量，也不是纯粹的邪恶力量。最重要的是，它们是资本的力量。它们做出的绝大多数选择和事情都归结为一个问题。我们如何能把这个地区变得足够好，让人愿意在这里花时间和金钱？
The problem is that this is a private group. These bids are responsible for keeping property values at the same level or even raising property values because that's what building owners are interested in. That means that the business improvement districts are not concerned if rents rise, if commercial rents rise. And while these higher commercial rents might benefit property owners, they can push out small local businesses. Small stores are forced out of business because they can't pay those rents. If you own a small barber shop or craft shop or gym yoga studio or something, the Business Improvement District is not that interested in you. Here's Daniel Kudla again.
问题在于这是一个私人集团。这些商业改进区负责保持财产价值处于同一水平甚至提高财产价值，因为这正是业主们感兴趣的。这意味着商业改进区并不关心租金上涨，如果商业租金上涨的话。虽然这些较高的商业租金可能会让业主受益，但它们可能会挤走当地的小企业。小商店被迫停业，因为他们付不起这些租金。如果你经营一家小理发店、工艺品店、健身瑜伽工作室或类似的东西，商业改进区其实并不那么对你感兴趣。这是丹尼尔·库德拉再次发言。
There's definitely a tie between increased gentrification in a lot of mid-sized larger North American cities coinciding with the formation of bids. Officially bids report to the city, but recent audits show that some cities aren't keeping as close tabs on bids as they're supposed to. And if the public has any opinion on that, there's not much they can do. Because bids are private groups. Their members can't get voted out on election day. But of course, not everyone agrees with bid critics.
在中小型和大型北美城市的士绅化加剧与商业改进区的成立之间，绝对存在着联系。官方上商业改进区向市政府报告，但最近的审计显示，一些城市并没有像它们应该的那样密切关注商业改进区。如果公众对此有任何意见，他们也无能为力。因为商业改进区是私人群体。它们的成员无法在选举日被投票下台。当然，并非所有人都同意商业改进区批评者的看法。
Tom Harris of the Times Square Alliance bid says a lot of those critiques of policing, of minimal oversight, don't land anymore. I would say it's completely the opposite of do what these property owners say to do. The mayor has a rep on our board. The controller has a rep on our board. We have resident reps. And look, if you live in Times Square, you're not shy. And our residents tend to dominate our meetings because they care about their neighborhood the way everyone cares about their neighborhood.
时代广场联盟商业改进区的汤姆·哈里斯表示，关于警务、监督不足的许多批评已经不再成立了。我要说，这完全与听从这些业主的话相反。市长在我们的董事会有代表。审计长在我们的董事会有代表。我们有居民代表。而且听着，如果你住在时代广场，你可不会害羞。我们的居民往往在我们的会议上占主导地位，因为他们像其他人关心自己的街区一样关心他们的街区。
The Times Square bid is actually known as one of New York's more inclusive creative bids. Unlike some of the more heavy-handed ones, the Times Square Alliance doesn't simply relocate unhoused people. Instead, they connect them with nearby resources, and they've done this more or less from the beginning. In the 90s, they helped open a supportive housing hotel for folks living on the street
时代广场商业改进区实际上被认为是纽约更具包容性、更有创意的商业改进区之一。与一些手段更严厉的商业改进区不同，时代广场联盟不仅简单地重新安置无家可归者。相反，他们将他们与附近的资源联系起来，而且他们基本上从一开始就这么做了。在90年代，他们帮助在时代广场为露宿街头的人们开设了一家支持性住房酒店。
in Times Square. Lauren Henry Tom also says that bids are able to take action on the needs of their specific neighborhood. Tom Biddle Bids are a little bit more nimble and can move quicker than the city government. We're sort of like a wave runner and the city is a cruise ship. So we can move a little bit more quickly and we can pilot things and see if they work a lot easier than the city can. Bids often get things done and fast.
劳伦·亨利·汤姆还表示，商业改进区能够针对他们特定街区的需求采取行动。汤姆·比德商业改进区比市政府更灵活、行动更快。我们有点像水上摩托艇，而城市就像一艘游轮。所以我们可以行动得更快一些，并且可以试行一些事情，比城市更容易看出它们是否奏效。商业改进区通常能把事情办成，而且速度很快。
Today, in addition to working with the city to host New Year's Eve, the Times Square Alliance puts on 80 live shows a year. They run a public art project where every night at midnight, 364 days a year, a local artist takes over all the billboards in Times Square. It's cool. And back in 2009, when the city wanted to turn the busiest stretch of Broadway into a pedestrian street for much of the day, they asked the Times Square bid to help spearhead that project.
今天，除了与城市合作举办新年夜活动之外，时代广场联盟每年举办80场现场演出。他们运营着一个公共艺术项目，每年364天，每天午夜，当地艺术家都会接管时代广场的所有广告牌。这很酷。早在2009年，当市政府希望将百老汇最繁忙的一段在一天中的大部分时间变成步行街时，他们请时代广场联盟协助牵头该项目。
And they did. Pedestrianizing Broadway has been probably one of the greatest things for public space in the last 40 years. Before that, Times Square was two streets that crossed and a lot of signs. Now it's a vibrant public space and we created a destination. In short, bids are a paradox. They exist ultimately to serve businesses and property owners. They're not democratic institutions.
他们确实做到了。将百老汇步行化可能是过去40年来对公共空间做过的最伟大的事情之一。在此之前，时代广场是两条交叉的街道和许多广告牌。现在它是一个充满活力的公共空间，我们创造了一个目的地。简而言之，商业改进区是一个悖论。它们的存在最终是为了服务于企业和业主。它们不是民主机构。
And yet they are responsible for a lot of the special things that can make a city feel like home. I had that experience myself. One of my good friends, who's a poet in California was visiting. I walked with her through Bryant Park in Midtown. And I said, look at this. Isn't this awful? The business improvement district runs this public space as though it's their private
然而，它们却负责了许多能让城市感觉像家的特殊事物。我自己也有过这种经历。我的一位好朋友，一位在加利福尼亚的诗人来访。我和她一起穿过中城的布莱恩特公园。我说，看看这个。这不是很糟糕吗？商业改进区把这个公共空间当成他们自己的私人空间来管理。
space. And she said, what's bad? There are lovely restaurants. People are sitting on the benches and Rita Dove, who was the US poet laureate at that time, was going to give a noonday poetry reading. So my friend said, what's wrong with you? This is great.
她说，哪里不好了？这里有可爱的餐馆。人们坐在长椅上，而当时担任美国桂冠诗人的丽塔·多夫将要在这里进行一场中午的诗歌朗诵。所以我朋友说，你脑子有毛病吧？这太棒了。
Who cares who's paying for it? Bids are addressing a failure of the system. A lot of things that bids do, public events, nice decorations, these are things that cities often can't or at least don't pay for. The question is whether private businesses with ill-defined authorities should be the ones filling in that gap. It's in a way fortunate that Mr. Moneybags comes in to pay for things
谁在乎是谁在出资？商业促进区（BID）正在解决系统失效的问题。许多BID所做的事情，比如公共活动、精美的装饰，都是城市往往无力承担、或者至少不愿出资去做的事情。问题在于，这些权限界定不清的私营企业是否应该成为填补这一空白的主体。从某种程度上说，有钱人来为我们在公共空间中真正需要的东西买单是一件幸运的事。
that we really need in public space. But I don't think we have a full democracy in a city if we allow private organizations to control who can use public space. We already have a way of paying into shared space. And that's taxation, a city government. If companies paid into the government instead of the bid, that money could go to amenities and neighborhoods all over the city. But bids have become so ingrained in our political process, that's unlikely to happen anytime soon.
但我不认为，如果我们允许私人组织控制谁能使用公共空间，这座城市就能实现真正的民主。我们其实已经有了一种为共享空间出资的方式，那就是税收和市政府。如果企业把钱交个政府而不是BID，这笔资金就可以用于全市各个街区的公共设施。但在我们的政治进程中，BID已经根深蒂固，这种情况在短期内不太可能会发生。
Perhaps the thing that should make us the most squeamish about all this is just how much a bid looks like a mini-democracy. They vote, they tax themselves, and they decide how to use that money. But it's property owners who get the loudest say. In this country, we tried that before, having a democracy where the landowners were the only ones who had a voice. And we left it behind for a very good reason. Whatever you feel about bids, one thing they do show is that there is an appetite for exciting,
也许最让人感到不安的是，BID看起来就像是一个微型民主体制。它们投票、自我征税，并决定如何使用这笔资金。但拥有最大话语权的是业主。在这个国家，我们以前尝试过这种让地主拥有发言权的民主形式，而我们抛弃它是出于非常充分的理由。无论你对BID作何感想，它们至少表明了一点，那就是人们对令人兴奋的、雄心勃勃的，当然有时也是代价高昂的城市规划项目有着强烈的需求。
ambitious, and yes, sometimes costly, urban planning projects. I mean, just look at New Year's Eve in Times Square. Love it or hate it, it's nothing if not testimony to the fact that people want to come together. In celebration of the slow descent of the ball and a rocking display of confetti, sure. But also in celebration of urban space, where we can get together on the streets and sidewalks that we publicly share. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Katie Thornton, edited by Kelly Prime with help from Vivienne Leigh, mixed by Martín González, music by Swan Real, fact-checking by Graham Hayesha.
我是说，看看时代广场的跨年夜就知道了。无论你喜欢还是讨厌它，它都充分证明了一个事实：人们渴望聚在一起。当然，是为了庆祝水晶球的缓缓降落和震撼人心的彩带喷洒，但也是为了庆祝城市空间，在这里我们可以在共同拥有的街道和人行道上欢聚。本周的《99% Invisible》由凯蒂·桑顿（Katie Thornton）报道，凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）编辑，薇维安·利（Vivienne Leigh）协助，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）混音，斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）配乐，格雷厄姆·海耶沙（Graham Hayesha）核实事实。
For more about the queer history of Times Square, check out the book Times Square Red, Times Square Blue by Samuel Delaney. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Jacob Medina Gleason, me Roman Mars, and Nina Potuck. This is Nina's last episode with us.
想了解更多关于时代广场的酷儿历史，请阅读塞缪尔·德莱尼（Samuel Delaney）的书《时代广场红，时代广场蓝》。凯西·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉什玛·道恩（Lashma Dawn）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、还有我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）以及尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）。这是尼娜在我们这里的最后期节目。
She's been filling in for this year and just doing an amazing job. We were so lucky to have spent time with her. So thank you, Nina, and I'm sure we will be working together again very soon. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building
她今年一直在代班，而且表现极其出色。我们非常幸运能和她共度这段时光。所以谢谢你，尼娜，我相信我们很快还会再次合作。99%的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大厦。
in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites we're making a real go of it on blue sky if you want to join us on blue sky. We also have our own discord server where we talk about the power broker we talk about all different episodes we talk about architecture we talk about flags we talk about all kinds of things there's a link to that discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，如果你想加入我们的Bluesky，我们在那里也在努力经营。我们还有自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里讨论《权力经纪人》，讨论各种不同的节目，讨论建筑，讨论旗帜，讨论各种各样的事情。该Discord服务器的链接以及99PI的所有往期节目都可以在99PI.org上找到。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。